[Music]
Hey everyone. Um, I'm Ean. I'm an
engineer here at Windsurf. And today
we'll be talking a little bit about um,
how to make the most out of your
development experience. how to make the
most out of this agenda flow that we all
now have exposure to with our idees. Um,
and also talk a little bit about how
these flows make us um, better
developers.
For those who are not aware, Windsurf is
in the dev tool space. Our flagship
product is the Windsurf editor um, which
is uh, oh, as you can see.
Okay, sorry.
Will it not share if I Okay. Um,
all right. Our flagship product is the
Windsor editor which is powered by our
agent Cascade. Um, which uh was actually
the first agentic IDE in the space.
after we launched a lot of tools, a lot
of similar products followed suit and
that they realized that this agent uh
experience was the way to go um with
this um with this IDE. Um so for those
who aren't aware or haven't tried it
out, highly suggest you try it out. But
before we actually get into how Windsor
does agents, how we do flows, um let's
take a step back. Let's talk about some
of the most iconic duos um till date uh
and and those that have really um won
that have been successful. Um
what are some of the characteristics of
of these duos and what has really led
them to be so successful? It wasn't that
each individual or each one of these
were the best at their position or they
were the best by far or considered the
GOAT. Um although some may argue
otherwise for some of these people. Um,
what made them so good was that together
as a team, they worked better than
everybody else and that's what led to
success. Um,
one of the most iconic duos, Pineapple
and Pizza. Uh, regardless of what you
all say, um, this is what makes duo
successful is that they work together
and they know each other. They
complement each other very well. Another
one of the most iconic duos. What this
reminds me of is how we think of our
agents or how we think of our coding
assistants. Um, a lot of times we fight
with them. We uh we ask ourselves like
why is it not getting us? Why is it
producing all this error errorprone
code? Why is it duplicating code? Why is
it removing code that we don't want it
to remove? Um, we also tend to abuse our
agent sometimes. We uh we tell it that
we're going to find it $1 million if it
doesn't do what we ask it to do. We also
tell it that it's going to go to jail if
it doesn't do what we want it to do. But
that's not how it's supposed to be. We
are supposed to treat our agents like we
would treat our uh running mate, our
teammate, our friend. And this is what
it's supposed to look like, right? Not
like what Tom and Jerry are. So, um it's
not your fault as developers. It's ours.
It's ours as the builders of these tools
to provide that experience for you to
make sure that you as developers um
you're actually able to work with these
agents that these agents understand you.
Um how do we fix this problem? How does
WinSurf approach this?
Before I dive in depth into that, let's
let's take a step back and look at um
how we've gotten to this point of
agents. uh the evolution of AI, how AI
has kind of evolved into what we see
today with these coding agents.
Back in 2022,
the ancient times, um we had to do
everything ourselves, right? It's it's
kind of terrifying. We had to write all
the code by ourselves. There was no AI
to really help us, right? There was just
Stack Overflow. Um and Google
in 2022 or late 2022 and moving on into
23, uh co-pilots were introduced. I
consider chat GBT uh barred at the time
um GitHub copilot as this kind of chat
interface this co-pilot kind of uh
experience where you would give a prompt
or an input you get a response really
good with simple Q&A and autocomplete
late 2024 this is when uh we saw the
first agents or what people like to call
agents um a lot of times people would
confuse uh confuse agents with workflows
but I think that was kind have cleared
up uh more recently and that agents now
are able to take this autonomy, they
take this independence, they operate um
iteratively, they adjust their
trajectories and they can perform these
larger scope tasks and um do things that
simple or single uh response single shot
co-pilots would not be able to do.
So another way to look at this is that
co-pilots were a little bit more
collaborative, right? We had to interact
at every single step of the process
while we're working with co-pilots. If
we ever were coding with Chad GBT, we'd
have to maybe paste in every file. We
would have to um individually send in
each response and Chad GBT would have to
work on things very step by step, right?
So we would just send an input or a
prompt, maybe add some extra context and
after the LLM ran its inference, we
would get the response. Agents then
introduced this autonomous nature where
we got had these models. Um, we also
allowed it to retrieve this context, but
on top of that, we introduced tool
calling and function calling, the
ability for agents to perform tasks, um,
perform these functions and actually be
able to execute things that co-pilots or
chatbots wouldn't necessarily be able to
do. What windsurf has done when we
launched was we realized that agents
really didn't solve the problems that um
co-pilots couldn't solve and co-pilots
didn't do everything that we would want
to do as developers as well. And so we
took the best of both worlds in that we
combined
we combined uh these models as well as
retrieving proper context uh figuring
out how to uh call tools properly in
addition with understanding the user
tracking the user's actions really uh
understanding their intent as developers
what they're going to do. So we
essentially took the best of both
worlds, right? Um, and so AI flows is
what Windsurf and Cascade introduced
back in November. And this is where a
lot of other companies, a lot of other
products that I'm sure you all know
today followed suit in that they
realized this simple chat interface or
even having an agent and a chat just
maybe didn't make sense. It only made
sense to provide one singular agentic
interface that collaborated with you as
a developer. And so Windsurf, our
editor, it took the best of both worlds
in that it combined this collaborative
power of a chatbot interface with some
of these autonomous and tool calling
capabilities of an agent and molded them
together to work in perfect unison in
perfect sync. And this created a very
seamless um a very unified experience
where developers in AI could actually
operate as one, could operate as a team
rather than like these guys. So
how did WinServe do this? The first
thing we wanted to consider was this
concept of flow awareness. What this
meant was that we would have really
comprehensive reasoning and
understanding of the implicit user
intent. This is something that a lot of
agents actually don't really consider
right now and um you know even when
we're building this on the side we don't
actually think of what is really
important to the user. So, our main
emphasis when we were building Cascade
was understanding the user, tracking
their actions, their edits, their
commands, the terminal commands they've
run, um their anything that's in their
clipboard, um all the files that they've
recently edited, all these things are
tracked by Cascade so that Cascade
develops an understanding of what the
user has been doing and that is all
inputed into this agent's trajectory so
that the agent can then outline a much
more uh relevant set of steps that
aligns with what the user would be doing
or what may be doing in the future. And
so when you use Cascade, when you use
Windsurf tab, it almost feels like
Windsurf is predicting your your next
step. It's it's you know, it's almost
like an LLM. It predicts the next token.
In this case, Cascade is is predicting
or inferring what you would do next.
When you're using tab, it feels like
cascade or windsurf is reading your mind
because so much of this context of the
user's um actions as well as like this
uh understanding of the user over time
as the user interacts with cascade. This
is inputed into the context window and
this is what makes this agent so
powerful is that it understands the user
much better than a very general purpose
or independent agent.
On top of that, we have a
state-of-the-art context engine. We have
a talk on this tomorrow as well. But uh
we approach context differently than
other products in the space. We don't
just use a rag or embedding based search
approach. We leverage a combination of
multiple tools um in tandem to really
figure out what works best so that we
can understand your codebase, this
explicit context as strong and
comprehensively as possible. And what
this what this helps us do is as an
agent is it helps us get more accurate
results more relevant suggestions right
for your codebase um or for any of these
code suggestions right we have reduced
hallucinations we don't have to do any
guesswork because we understand the user
because we understand your codebase very
well we are able to provide a much more
tailored experience an experience that
actually outlines of what the user may
want and um it's grounded in this
centralized uh source of truth which is
this codebase that you're working in.
On top of that, we equip Cascade with
all of the best tools for this agent to
really perform that multi-step iterative
uh kind of set of tasks where it's not
just limited to that single response um
nature. It can actually call MCP
servers. It can leverage workflows.
Something we recently introduced where
now we are bringing together bridging
that gap between the unpredictability of
an agent and more of that deterministic
nature of a workflow, right? where
workflows we know exactly what's going
to happen and when it's going to happen.
And so with Windinsurf again our main
priority is to help developers as much
as possible. We realize that with agents
it's very unpredictable what's going to
happen and what they're going to do. And
so with workflows now this bridges that
gap. We can actually as users define a
set of steps for the agent to follow as
they're operating. On top of that we
allow Cascade to look at rules. Right?
These are rules that you can generate as
users. Um they could be file-based
rules. They can be rules that um you
always want the model to look at. You uh
maybe sometimes want the model to look
at. On top of that, Cascade can generate
memories of you as a user, some of your
preferences, memories of your codebase
so that it doesn't have to constantly
index, doesn't have to constantly
retrieve your codebase. And on top of
that, recently there's a lot of talk
about ATA A2A and like multiple agents.
Um recently we introduced multiple
simultaneous cascades working in tandem.
And so what this brings to us is it
allows Cascade now to have these
multiple different um you know
trajectories that understand each other,
understand the user and understand your
code base which allows us to be able to
complete tasks faster, more efficiently
and get things done um you know in the
way that we want to get them done. So
all these tools right there's a lot that
I left out here like the ability to
search the web and other things like
that. They empower Cascade to be able to
really give us this agentic feeling
while it's operating, right? And really
not just again an independent agent, but
one that understands us as users. Um,
but as engineers, how do we make the
most how do we get the most out of these
flows?
Uh, also known as engineer maxing. How
do we really max out what we get out of
the this experience? Uh, the way I like
to approach it, I'm sure you all are
somewhat familiar with this kind of set
of steps. We like to first explore um
discover our codebase, scope out our
task, then plan um then build and then
test out uh our our changes or anything
that the agent did. Um when discovering
we can leverage Cascade at every set um
of these steps, right? We want to
leverage Cascade to understand our
codebase to scope out our task,
determine this definition of done,
right? That's what an agent does, right?
It determines a definition of done and
outlines a set of steps. How can we tell
Cascade what that definition of done is
and talk through some of these goals? On
top of that, if we wanted to give more
direct context, we can appmentntion um
different files and directories. Um it's
also very important to plan with
Cascade, right? A lot of people just
say, "Hey, I'm just going to put in this
prompt and let Cascade or let this agent
just build everything for me." The best
way to go about this is create work with
the agent to understand you. And so what
that means is um create a planning file
outline like you know a set of tasks
with like maybe checkboxes to tell
Cascade hey you need to hit these set of
tasks to accomplish this definition of
done. Also outline rules to tell Cascade
how to behave that align with your
preferences.
And then we go into building work with
Cascade to actually execute this plan
that you've set for yourself. um edit
files one by one or multiple files at a
time and ensure Cascade is working with
this planning document um and actually
checking all the boxes and you'll see
that Cascade actually asks you
questions. It will check in with you as
a user as a developer, right? And you
like make sure to answer it very
clearly. Tell it, hey, you're doing this
incorrectly or hey uh let's actually
look at this first or let's look at um
this set of steps next, right? Um,
windsurf tab then provides us more
hands-on experience with autocomplete.
And on top of that, you can leverage
these simultaneous cascades and these
different MCP servers that allow you to
pull additional context and empower
cascade with these additional tools to
complete uh, you know, this agentic
experience. Lastly, then you want to
generate tests with cascade, right? Um,
generate, run, uh, fix your tests one by
one as it's iterating. You can leverage
workflows here which uh you know can you
can leverage to automate some of these
tasks and um at the end determine if
Cascade hit that DoD that definition of
done. If it didn't make sure Cascade
understands what it did wrong because
Cascade is building this learning of
you. It's building this embedding
representation of you as a developer. Um
and it's learning from that. So in the
future it knows where to not go wrong
and where to improve. Um, and then
lastly, then you want to commit to git
uh and and make sure that you're pushing
code that is functional.
So you and Cascade, right, don't think
of you guys as separate entities. We
want to think of you all as a merge, as
a team, right? As a peer programmer. Um,
you guys are working together to
accomplish tasks. And so this is how you
and Cascade should be. This is how
developers in Cascade should be. It
shouldn't be separate where you tell
Cascade, hey, just accomplish these set
of tasks. I'll come back in 30 minutes.
and um and we'll see what you did,
right? We're not at that level where
LLMs can do that just yet. And so really
work with Cascade, make it your friend,
and that is how you'll get the best uh
development experience out of these
agents.
[Music]